[Applaudissements]
le rideau tombe sur le sommet du G20 les
dirigeants satisfaits semblent prêts à
quitter l'Indonésie mais la rencontre
réservée encore une surprise à juste un
Trudeau un cameraman de la délégation
canadienne a capté un moment étonnant un
rare coup d'œil dans les coulisses de la
diplomatie un échange tendu entre le
président chinois et le premier ministre
du Canada
tout ce dont nous avons discuté a été
divulgué dans les journaux c'est
inapproprié a déclaré si Jean Ping par
l'entremise de son interprète la veille
Justin Trudeau avait abordé avec si Jean
Ping la question de l'ingérence chinoise
dans les élections canadiennes le bureau
du premier ministre avait rendu public
le contenu de cette conversation
et ce n'est pas comme ça que la
conversation s'est déroulée ajoute le
président chinois visiblement irrité lui
reprochant d'avoir déformé la vérité
juste à Trudeau tente une réplique
nous croyons à la liberté de parole dit
le Premier ministre tout entrons de
travailler ensemble de manière
constructive mais il y aura des choses
sur lesquelles nous ne serons pas
d'accord
il faut d'abord créer les conditions
gagnantes conclus si Jinping avant de
lui serrer la main et de lui tourner le
dos tout près la chef de cabinet de
Justin Trudeau semble déconcerté par la
scène qui vient de se dérouler sous ses
yeux clairement il était agité il était
pas content et puis moi je trouve que
c'est une menace voilée ce qu'il a dit à
Monsieur Trudeau encore des tensions
alors que le Canada vient de durcir le
temps contre Pékin et adapte sa
politique étrangère pour faire
contrepoids à la Chine ce que ça
confirme c'est que
validation bilatérale entre le Canada et
la chienne ne sont pas prêtes de
s'améliorer
juste un Trudeau refuse de dire si cet
épisode risque d'endommager encore plus
la relation entre les deux pays lui et
chie ont une vision différente de la
transparence a-t-il expliqué une réalité
que nos systèmes sont très différents
moi je prends régulièrement des
questions des médias je suis pas
offusqué quand on me met au défi il
persiste et signe je pense que les gens
savent très bien que pas toutes les
conversations ont toujours être facile
avec les autres chefs Justin Trudeau d'y
vouloir collaborer avec la Chine quand
c'est nécessaire et la confronter quand
il le faut le Premier ministre vient
d'avoir un avant-goût de ce qu'il peut
en coûter de tenir tête à une
superpuissance comme la Chine 90
secondes qui pourrait hanter leur
relation pour longtemps ici Louis Blouin
Radio-Canada à Bali on est de